President Trump said yesterday that
Cavanaugh will make an incredible
Supreme Court justice but also said he
wanted to hear both sides at Monday's
hearing a delay is certainly acceptable
we want to get to the bottom of
everything we want everybody to be able
to speak up and to speak out later on
the president blamed Democrats for
delaying a vote tweeting the Supreme
Court is one of the main reasons I got
elected president I hope Republican
voters and others are watching and
studying the Democrats playbook which
Assange is at the White House we should
good morning good morning Nora White
House officials met with Judge Brett
Kavanaugh here for hours over the past
two days talking through a strategy as
Kavanagh called senators to plead his
case Cavanaugh reportedly underwent a
tough practice session answering
questions about his past partying and
dating history as well as Christine
Blasi Ford's allegation the president
has stressed he fully supports Kavanagh
and feels badly for him that he's going
through this formally reopening the
FBI's background check on Kavanagh would
require a request from the White House
mr. Trump said Tuesday the FBI does not
want to be involved in a statement that
Justice Department said the FBI does not
make any judgment about the credibility
or significance of any allegation the
purpose of a background investigation is
to determine whether the nominee could
pose a risk to the national security of
the United States the statement also
added that Ford's allegation does not
involve any potential federal crime John
we thanks